and i have to say out loud
that in terms of responsibility and
escape plans
and what to do right you have it done on
lockdown and i do not
so i'm gonna give you that but the
second thing is i really believe this
is is that i love them more
[Laughter]
are you offended i really believe that
are you offended kalala i believe i love
my animals more
and that that can never be proven who
feeds them every day it has nothing to
do with it's the heart who gives them
water fresh water
that you're capable who who pets them
every day i don't know that you're
capable of that kind of life can you
list some like intangibles that you do
yeah well how what even how is what's
the measure how do you measure that
for me it's acts of service and i show
those acts of service every day
i'll i'll give you one tangible evidence
if i may um i do count kisses
so i count the amount of times like so
when you and i are laying together and
goby comes up to us
goby loves to kiss both of us both right
or julio that's that's a better example
because william is a
maniac when it comes to kissing i think
he's french
and he um i really do so
when julio is on us and i see sometimes
our heads are next to each other
so he'll go back and forth right you
pull away
after about five seconds because i'm not
into bestiality
and see that's why my love is deeper
because if no i'm not my no no no no
stop stop that came out
it's not bestiality right but i don't
even think of it
babe i don't want to get giardia or some
[ __ ] that will give me diarrhea
my point is i'm willing to do it out of
love and that's why
my love is greater you know how my you
know why my love is greater i
posted on instagram a video
of goby licking the inside of my mouth
and got a lot of [ __ ] for it are you
willing to do that that's how i know i
was willing to prove my love
that's not that was by accident you
thought that that was gonna get a lot of
hits and love and you that the
the comments were shocking to you i was
like oh they really hate this
and i was singing a beating so let this
be known today
right mm-hmm the colell is more
responsible but i have far more love
and i want to say that i want to say
that in in life
everyone in this room the mother always
gets [ __ ] on at the end no no
i'm going to talk about these boys too
right the amount of love i have
it's just deeper it's a deeper c you
think you love them more than i love
them
no interest your capability of love hang
on one second this word plays amazing
you who shows you more love jewel let's
start with george who shows you more
love who do you feel more loved
not out of words or actions wait don't
don't try to manipulate him
you're you have your own love language
how you receive and view love how you
perceive love
who do you feel more loved by
hey gilbert you want to go first on this
one we'll go first this is why it's
tricky for me because i have two love
languages when i took the test or top
one physical touch got to grab them
titties on me
so who grabs cities more bobby so here's
the thing it's physical
touch and words of affirmation okay
kalila's words
have definitely picked me up a lot and
she actually is genuinely interested
but here's physical here's the thing she
doesn't interesting
but here she does not there is a
playfulness you have with me where you
will
kitty touching we play around i
definitely feel loved from that
gilbert i can't jiggle your balls it's
inappropriate but she doesn't i feel
close they stop you
yeah let me step it may i stop you there
right
is she trying to get you
so i don't have the hollywood strings is
she trying to get you
on a network show and actually has
has pushed it along so that you could do
this
who brought you on this podcast all
right oh
so my point is is that what is she
willing to do
everything in my power is that i don't
have that hollywood pool because you're
the most hollywood in this room i don't
either
i had i had to pull you think that it
was like an
easy call no it was no it was pulling
levers
and mechanisms and things that you will
never be able to understand
so um god okay george your turn
well i think bobby gives bursts of
warmth and kaleila
was that yeah those steady warmth i give
steady warmth
but steady warmth i believe it's not it
is fake
but burst burst is real right because
that's in between those bursts
george i have a question for you follow
up my follow-up question is
in between those bursts of warmth what
do you feel is it a dead cold
um yeah there's sometimes some icy air
that hits but there's bursts of warmth
too yeah yeah
that's life bud yeah warmth and icy air
you had to have both you have good and
evil you know
fire and ice baby so george who do you
feel more loved by
um right now neither of you this is
pretty scary uh
very good answer i feel like most of the
time you kalila
thank you then uh every so often bobby
comes in and boom boom boom
yeah here's here's the deal his love is
big and shiny he's a deal friend right
you know you can buy into fake love
all you want okay but i don't buy into
it what's his son's name
his son george jr what do they call him
did i get that right though yeah that's
the easiest one we already talked about
it doesn't matter and i only answer one
question is it george jr and we move on
right not george jr what number george
the what the third
nope the fourth nope the fifth yep yep
yeah
then there's that burst thank you
the fifth the fifth right that's
ridiculous
change it yeah that's a lot somebody in
their line you know one of your sons
well he's actually
more like the 14th uh george kimmel just
uh they had different middle names boy
back in the day
oh wow wow you can't stop what are you
up to
why kinda let's just
let's just go back i want to end with
this may i end with my life can i do
the final statement and then we'll move
on okay
the final statement is is that my heart
is an abyss of love it's endless
it drops for eternity right
you guys have love like a little balloon
pocket
of love and you you it's there
right but mine's so deep and i'm gonna
say this
as my final thing
we don't get a rebuttal no okay i love
all three of you
so very much and may wisdom
and the torch of life and your offspring
travel through time within each
layer of glacier ice and fire
right and beneath the wind of my sea
we will create a magical
temptation and life everlasting
foundation of creating
our miracles
i feel loved i feel loved thank you